because I see like obviously you and you
and young boy had a great project
together yeah did you use I'm sure you
saw the interview you just did right
here kind of showed a lot of remorse for
some of the energy he put out into the
world yeah
um great interview great interview I was
gonna say like do you see that side of
him being someone who's like you know
that close with him because we don't
know young boy like he's kind of a
recluse you know even before he got
locked up I feel like like you know I
feel like
I feel like yeah people don't people
don't see a lot of sides him but you
know they now he's starting to open up
more for people so
so that's dope you know and he's Mormon
now
he joined the church I think he's
joining the Latter-Day Saints Church
yeah he's he lives in Utah
look you can't live in Utah too long and
not end up being a Mormon respectfully
they'll get you out there yeah I mean I
don't know much about it it's a solid
religion it's a yeah it is what it is